voilà où en est cette nouvelle journée
de mobilisation le cortège où est-il
exactement en ce moment même on est
actuellement boulevard de l'hôpital et
le cortège il a bien bien avancé puisque
on touche presque à la fin en tout cas
la dispartion est bientôt prévue puisque
placé d'italie n'est plus qu'à quelques
centaines de mètres d'où je me trouve
actuellement elle vous l'entendez
peut-être une ambiance bonne enfant
assez jovial avec beaucoup de musique et
beaucoup de slogans anti gouvernement
notamment concernant cette fameuse
réforme des retraites qui mobilisait les
troubles depuis plusieurs semaines est
le but de ce rassemblement est bien
c'est de raviver la flamme réellement
pour mobiliser les troupes avant la
rentrée puisque c'est maintenant les
vacances et dans ce cortège il ya
plusieurs syndicats comme vous l'avez
dit gregory à face eu la cgt et force
ouvrière ont encore solidaires je vous
propose notamment d'écouter les
secrétaires généraux de ces syndical de
fo force ouvrière cgt et également effet
su écouter les la détermination est
toujours là même les sondages ne varie
pas et vous avez pu constater qu'on a
l'ornement une majorité qui pataugent de
plus en plus pour expliquer leurs contre
réforme
on a eu quelques anecdotes
croustillantes
valeur du point qui évoluera sur un
indice qui n'existe pas donc voilà les
têtes détermination elle est toujours la
même
et donc
malgré cette période de congés scolaires
il y avait encore du monde dans la rue
et encore des mobilisations importantes
et n'est pas décidé à lâcher le morceau
comme on dit le gouvernement a un projet
qui est lacunaire dans ses projections
financières qui n'est pas garantie
juridiquement ni constitutionnellement
dont on a plus de certitudes que de
certitudes les instances y ont été
consultés sont toutes dans le même sens
opposé à ce projet donc aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas de raison de baisser les
bras et d'être pessimiste tout le monde
a compris que la roue nous disait que le
système allait corriger des défaillances
en réalité il va au mieux reprendre les
dispositions de solidarité qui existent
d'ores et déjà dans le système actuel
c'est ce qu'a constaté le conseil d'état
lui même et dans bien des cas il va
plutôt dégradée des droits que les
améliorer du côté des professeurs la
détermination est vraiment conséquente
les la colère est vraiment importante
d'autant que les revalorisation promise
peine à se concrétiser le problème
majeur le la le fil rouge c'est quand
même un sentiment de mépris quand même
très nettes par un ministère qui dit
nous faire confiance qui dit souhaiter
notre notre bonheur et finalement on se
rend compte que tous les propos vont
dans l'autre sens c'est un discrédit qui
est porté sur l'école et qui est porté
sur sur les enseignants vous l'avez
entendu la colère gronde toujours et la
mobilisation et le maître homos ils sont
toujours motivés à se mobiliser en tout
cas le cortège est bientôt arrivée a
placé d'italie la dispersion va donc
bientôt être annoncés à savoir qu'un
nouvel appel à se mobiliser a été lancé
pour le 8 mars
merci mon âme ou dès lors en direct donc
des rues de paris